Welcome back everyone it's Charlie a first look
at Spider-Man 4 hjust dropped so we'll break it all
down there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
I have a whole animatic from the final fight
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos Marvel's Brazil Comic Con panel is
happening this week CCXP they already released
a couple really big trailers for Ant-Man and the
wasp Quantumamia and Guardians of the Galaxy 3
in the past couple of days I think they also
dropped a new Loki season 2 trailer during a
recent panel as well of course I'll do videos
for everything as soon as they release online
versions of all that stuff but you probably just
saw in your fees we got a really cool first look
at Toby Maguire's Spider-Man 4. the reason this
happened is because they'd already been making
the movie when it was canceled back in the day
and there's a statute of limitations like the
people that posted all this stuff were like we're
not going to get sued Sony's not gonna sue us Sam
Raimi had finished the story they had a bunch of
new suits that were made ready to go also explain
what was supposed to happen in the movie as well
because we know basically what the plot was going
to be and I'll explain what's changed now because
Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield have both come
back as Spider-Man like a couple years ago there
was zero chance that we would ever see this stuff
but the first big thing that you probably saw
posted in your fees that leaked out was John
malkovich's vulture suit he was going to play
a version of the vulture and they were going to
say that he was called the vulture because nothing
was left of his victims except for the bones like
that's how hardcore he was going to be during the
movie he would have still been a technology-based
vulture like MCU Michael Keaton's Fulcher but it
would have been a much more organic Vibe like the
comic book version of the character his daughter
get this was going to be played by Angelina Jolie
who would have also been a version of vulture
rest during the movie this is a small part of
the final fight like I had the entire video but
it just goes on and on so you kind of get the idea
foreign
but what was supposed to happen with Spider-Man
4 is that it looked like they were gonna lose
their Uncle Ben cameos the actor that played him
wasn't going to be available for the movie and
they might also have lost Kirsten Dunst and they
couldn't bring back James Franco because they
killed him off during Spider-Man 3 so because
they didn't have Harry Osborne and they didn't
have Mary Jane they were going to introduce
Felicia Hardy black cat the vulture was going
to be the main villain and he was going to lead
a Sinister Six team the lizard Dr Kurt Connors
from the previous Spider-Man films was going to
turn evil as the lizard there would be a small
romance Arc with Felicia Hardy's black cat she
would flip sides she'd be a little bit evil a
little bit good during the movie the vulture
would be responsible for creating Electro so
that character would happen you can see that they
reused a lot of these ideas for Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man like they did full-on lizard
then they did Electro they did a bit of a team up
in Amazing Spider-Man 2 but they were also going
to do Mysterio which they're finally doing now but
it was going to be Bruce Campbell so it was going
to be a slightly older version of Quentin Beck I'm
going to try and make it more intimate find the
heart of of what made Spider-Man great originally
in the comic books I'm going to try and return
to the central core of the character that I fell
in love with and that way I try and make it better
they had done a little bit of pre-production those
are actual storyboards from the movie and this
is a portion of the script that I'll read here
so this is only a couple pages but it sets
the background for what was going on during
Spider-Man 4 so the mysterious plot of Spider-Man
4 becomes known while I'm reading from this I'll
cobble together and edit with images from Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man film so it makes a little more
sense we open up in the sky a Feather Falls to the
ground just as it does a slew of bank robbers pour
out as they look up at Spider-Man swinging down
gracefully Landing in a spider-like position he
beats down the criminals as the cops arrive and
the Webhead swings into the alleyway he removes
his mask revealing to us to be Peter Parker Parker
enters the Daily Bugle to reveal that JJ has been
removed as editor in Adriano tombs has taken his
place the vulture tombs is a hardened bold and
scared man who also doesn't have a sense of humor
By Night tombs turns into the vulture and begins
to Rob many banks across the city by morning the
headline spreads across the city quick backstory
John Malkovich was going to play the vulture in
this movie so picture John Malkovich when you're
thinking of Adrian tombs Spider-Man begins to
investigate the case with a utility belt that
is equipped with a mini crime case he Yanks out
a small magnifying glass and starts out over the
scene of the crime he notices the feather he picks
it up Spider-Man swings into the ESU University at
the ding of midnight scrolling over the feather
using a DNA scanner machine Parker finds out
that the DNA belongs to Adrian tombs the next day
Mary Jane calls Peter for lunch to meet her real
father Peter arrives at the Louvre kitchen with
a suit clearly not fit for him accompanied with a
stash of roses he drops them at the sight of her
father Adrian tombs both Peter and tombs shake
hands this being an awkward scene we move our cut
to Peter and MJ's new Penthouse apartment the two
are arguing over the idea that the man can't be
trusted it in that in fact he is the vulture Mary
Jane leaves in anger so they're already changing
the comics quite a bit like Adrian tomb's vulture
is not Mary Jane's father but then in the next
part of the story Adrian tombs winds up causing
an accident at Electro Corp and creates the
Max Dillon version of Electro then he slowly
puts together his Sinister Six team so it would
have been John Malkovich leading a version of
that team the way they were going to explain the
Spider-Man black cat romance during the events of
Spider-Man 4 is that Mary Jane was going to leave
Peter Parker and move to Los Angeles to become an
actress so he was going to be single then a little
bit of time goes by and he catches Felicia Hardy
black cat committing a crime they wind up in bed
together that begins their relationship and then
she winds up trying to help him take down this
Sinister Six I don't really know if people would
have been willing to accept that love triangle
with black hat and Mary Jane after they spent so
much time developing that Mary Jane relationship
and all the drama and all the weird stuff that
happened during Spider-Man 3. what ended up
happening though is the big third Act twist is the
black cat was going to secretly betray Spider-Man
because Adrian tombs had been holding her sister
hostage so it would have been this big double
cross she Yanks the rug out from under him but
then triple crosses the vulture later and helps
Spider-Man take him down they wind up winning by
the end of the movie but then Peter apologizes to
Aunt May for all these problems he's been causing
and he finds out that Mary Jane still wants to be
with him in Los Angeles so remember in Spider-Man
2 when he threw the costume in the trash right
out of the comic books Spider-Man no more he does
the same thing off the Brooklyn Bridge he throws
the mask off the Brooklyn Bridge then goes to Los
Angeles to be with Mary Jane the reason why that
movie didn't get made is as Sam Raimi felt like
they never cracked the script they went through
three different writers so by the time it was
getting ready to shoot he told Amy Pascal who's
been their Spider-Man person producer at Sony for
a long time that he didn't want to have another
Spider-Man 3 situation and make a disappointing
movie so he told Amy Pascal to go ahead and reboot
the Spider-Man character like they'd already been
playing planning to do and that's where you get
to Amazing Spider-Man with Andrew Garfield which
they announced just a little while after that what
an interesting thought that they'd actually been
planning on rebooting Spider-Man as far back
as Spider-Man 3 so they had been developing
Spider-Man 4 while they were planning on rolling
out Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man I think
Sony was just waiting to see if Sam Raimi was just
going to unfurl some Masterpiece of Spider-Man 4
it's like oh okay we'll make this instead of
doing Andrew Garfield but they wanted to have
Andrew Garfield waiting in the wings just in case
that didn't work out which obviously did not in
Sam Raimi later actually reacted to Tom Holland's
recasting too he was actually surprisingly happy
with the idea to take the character back to high
school do a much younger version of Spider-Man
and I'm really glad that Marvel's taking it to
high school I think that's going to be refreshing
and just like my favorite of the Spider-Man comic
books and I have a lot of faith that they really
know their stuff the funny thing watching that
Sam Raimi already came back to do Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness so it's already come full
circle with all the Easter eggs Spider-Man came
back to the MCU Sam Raimi came back to direct more
Marvel movies Toby Maguire said when he came back
one of his big notes when they were writing all
of his scenes in Spider-Man no way home is that
they shouldn't go into too much detail about
what had happened to his Spider-Man after the
events of Spider-Man 3. that's why they're only
a couple of light references because now that he
was back there was a chance they could actually
do some of that in a news story they've already
done the vulture a couple times now like Michael
Keaton just came back in the morbius movie It's
morbid time but there's still a ton of stuff
from Toby Maguire's Spider-Man 4 that they could
incorporate into a new movie even if it's just
part of some other movie that he appears in we
do know that he eventually married Mary Jane they
had a daughter that's basically his version of
Mayday Parker from the comics and currently in
his Universe he continues to act as Spider-Man
saving people his daughter sounded like she was
very young so he hasn't come close to retiring
or anything like that or passing the mantle on to
her let me know in the comments though which movie
do you want Toby Maguire to come back in Sony
has all kinds of crossover plans obviously but
Avengers six Secret Wars in the MCU is probably
pretty likely but that was essentially what
Andrew Garfield was talking about in the deleted
scenes that they put in the extended edition of
Spider-Man no way home when they released it in
theaters there was a scene of him saying we should
do this again sometime I'll get your phone number
after the big battle we should do this again like
I'll hang out it's nice yeah for sure yeah it's
a good idea I'll just grab your number at the
end of it the battle you got it doing it again
sometime was basically them doing it again during
Avengers 6 Secret Wars like I said though big
news this week is that Marvel has a big Comic
Con panel at ccxp they showed a couple big new
trailers this last week so I'll do videos for
whatever they wind up bringing tomorrow everyone
click here for that new Deadpool 3 Loki teaser
video that Ryan Reynolds just released and click
here for my new Ant-Man quantumania Kang video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!